alors la question idéologique est elle
vraiment au coeur du problème dans la
municipale ne put municipalité
écologistes comme le sous-entend gérald
darmanin on attend vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme verte et france place
au décryptage
est avec nous pour en parler alexis
poulain éditorialistes rt france bonsoir
alexis merci soir sera avec nous et
d'ici là vos côtés délégué unité sgp
police fo à marseille bonsoir et dc de
mer sont réellement à vous d'être là une
affaire de sécurité qui devient
éminemment politique alexis ya à six
mois de la présidentielle oui évidemment
surtout que la ville de lyon était
anciennement aux mains de gérard collomb
proche des manuels macron qui avait aidé
à fonder le parti en marche elle a été
volé ou gagner plus tôt par élevées lors
des dernières municipales qui ont vu la
république en marche vers un score assez
petit et donc il ya comme une revanche
l'idée de dire que les écolos les maires
élevés notamment à lyon n'en ferai pas
assez sur la sécurité des citoyens c'est
un peu la rhétorique de gérald darmanin
le toujours plus sales toujours plus
dans la la surveillance les drones qui
avait été retoqué pourtant par le
conseil d'état et qui reviennent la loi
sécurité globale qui était une once de
surveillance totale on a l'impression
que gérald darmanin souhaite surveiller
toujours plus or il y a déjà des caméras
et elle fonctionne alors faut-il en
mettre davantage est-ce que ça empêchera
les points de deal le problème de la
caméra c'est qu'elle arrive au dernier
maillon c'est à dire que entre le point
de deals et l'arrivage de la marchandise
ya quand même tout un une chaîne qui l'a
est plus difficile à atteindre le trafic
de drogue c'est d'abord les cartels
c'est aussi les différents débarquement
la police travaille sur tous ces fronts
là mais la caméra c'est vraiment ce
qu'il reste à la fin quand on n'a
vraiment pas réussi à lutter contre ce
fléau qu'est la drogue et décide
clairement gérald darmanin qui
critiquent la politique du maire de lyon
lui demande d'installer davantage de
deux caméras
gris bridoux c'est qu'il affirme
pourtant que cette ville était plutôt
calme
et qu'elle dispose de suffisamment de
caméras vous quelle est la réalité du
terrain vous avez eu certainement de vos
collègues lyonnais
alors nous serons effectivement on a ses
problématiques année nationale n'est pas
propre à l'agglomération lyonnaise les
mêmes soucis sur marseille en a ni ce
qui est assez avant gardiste sur le
sujet je vous cache pas que aujourd'hui
on a certaines effectivement l'idéologie
politique certaine quelque part franche
des deux côtés politique effectivement
et de l'électorat en question qui
freinent des quatre fers pour pas que
ceux ci soient bien en place et lorsque
la vidéo aujourd'hui la vidéo
effectivement surveillance existe et ben
en fait elle est utilisée soit
uniquement pour qu'elles ce qu'on
appelle la vidéo-verbalisation donc pour
ça pas grand chose en terme de
vidéoprotection c'est simplement pour
vulgariser le l'idée et aux
téléspectateurs c'est simplement pour
verbaliser des véhicules double file ou
stationnement gênant et nous ce qu'on
veut c'est la vidéoprotection et la
nuance elle est très importante et c'est
là que le dogmatique brand sens au
niveau politique car on a des personnes
qui sont en l'occurrence qui on refuse
effectivement qu'on utilise pour lutter
contre cela fait la délinquance de voie
publique la d'evp parce que la
vidéoprotection ça permet de faire
baisser un sentiment d'insécurité d'où
nos concitoyens sachant qu'ils ne sont
jamais seul est la seconde chance est de
faire baisser le sentiment d'impunité
car les vies de la vidéoprotection de
permet aujourd'hui pour les enquêteurs
d'investigation de pouvoir travailler en
profondeur sur le modus operandi
certains criminels les directions de
fuite la possibilité de repérage avant
avant effectivement des faits qui
peuvent être commis donc une véritable
aujourd'hui il ya tout un travail en
amont et en aval qu'on arrive à faire
aujourd'hui avec avec l'ami de
protection et c'est vrai que l'on sait
qu'il ya un frein un tiers parti
certaine partie de l'électorat qui
aujourd'hui le refuse à marseille on a
eu l'arrivée du présent dans le public
qui nous a permis aujourd'hui de
remettre la promesse qui a été faite on
verra si elle est respectée mais plus de
400 de caméras de vidéoprotection parce
que de façon très pragmatique sans faire
de politique occulte c'était l'outil
aujourd'hui nécessaire idée on apparente
pour prendre le cas de marseille pour
revenir et je suis je comme je maîtrise
d'autant plus ni ceux ci c'est deux fois
moins d'habitants où marseille et on a
deux fois plus de cas bien de caméras de
vidéoprotection ce n'est pas normal
radix me poulin vous avez cité tout à
l'heure un gérard collomb évidemment
ancien maire de la ville de lyon ancien
ministre de l'intérieur en tout cas lui
et il a une explication sur sur ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans son ancienne
ville
il y a un problème avec la nouvelle
majorité qui se refuse à prendre des
mesures importantes contre l'insécurité
qui se multiplient dans la ville cette
majorité ne veut pas prendre en compte
les problèmes de sécurité il y a un
problème à partir du moment où les
délinquants savent qu'ils n'auront pas
une répression en phase 2 qui sera
sévère alexis poulain évidemment on est
dans ce que vous décriviez tout à
l'heure on est dans la politique mais
tout de même est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
peu en fond de vérité dans cette voie là
on sait très bien que les europe
ecologie les verts ne sont pas forcément
connus pour moi voilà leur fermeté en
tout cas ce n'est pas leur approche de
lutte contre l'insécurité
voilà du vrai du faux nom dans tout ça
je crois qu'il ya un peu de mauvaise foi
peut-être un constat aussi mais je ne
crois pas qu'une majorité quelle qu'elle
soit la tête d'une ville n'ait intérêt à
ce que l'insécurité grandit donc je ne
vois pas quel serait le calcul qu'elle
serait l'idéologie derrière celle du
maire élevé de lyon pour laisser faire
les délinquants je crois qu'il est assez
sévère avec les délinquants ils
parlaient de 60 vidéos caméras à la
duchère alors il ya des moyens aussi est
ce que les budgets sont suffisants il ya
aussi pour rassurer et protéger les
populations c'est d'abord et avant tout
des policiers des policiers formés des
policiers sur le terrain on se rappelle
bien sûr de cette police de proximité
qui a disparu qu'on voudrait faire
revenir d'une façon ou d'une autre la
question également de la police
municipale armée ou non armé qui mérite
d'être posée anne hidalgo a tranché à
paris donc je pense pas que derrière
elle veille à une volonté que la
délinquance se multiplient dans une
ville comme étant peut-être une autre
approche de la lutte contre l'insécurité
évidemment qu'il n'y a pas de volonté
que ça s'aggrave et dc de votre avis sur
cette question c'est tout simplement une
approche différente
ans est lui en tête au niveau on est
vraiment effectivement de la politique
politicienne et on est en prennent
dogmatisme quand j'entends effectivement
qu'on parle de vidéoprotection parce
qu'il ya là de protection et peut-être
des caméras mais il faut voir comment
les utiliser comment les orienter est ce
que le parc est effectivement efficace
et efficiente est-ce que les ponctions
de police ont accès à ce système là
parce que je veux prendre un cas très
très très simple et très pratique sur
marseille par exemple on a un seul point
d'exploitation pour les policiers
nationaux pour cinq arrondissements
serre que c'est totalement saoul calibre
est donc bien aussi une volonté de
certaines y ait certaines dogmatisme
effectivement qui laissent faire qui ne
ne répare pas les caméras qu'ils
devraient l'être qu'ils ne fassent ne
permet pas d'accéder à la technologie
qui nous permettait de pouvoir
travailler d'autant plus facilement da
c'est la même chose la seconde chose
opposer les renforts d'effectifs la
vidéoprotection c'est quelque part
effectivement être un avantage des
citoyens aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
les deux lui faut des fonctions de
police pour exploiter les caméras ni il
faut défendre la police pour arriver
rapidement et faire cesser l'infraction
et interpeller les individus comme étant
des agressions quelle qu'elle soit mais
nous avons aussi besoin de ses moyens
technologiques effectivement qui est une
arme à part entière et un arsenal pour
pouvoir lutter contre les faits de
délinquance quel qu'il soit l expo là je
vais vous faire écouter une première
réaction celle d'eric un nom d'emprunt
puisqu'il n'a pas souhaité donner son
nom c'est justement un habitant de ce
quartier l'est du cher qui nous dit que
les choses se sont clairement dégradée
au fil des années oui une ex à la une et
une escalade et jusqu'à présent on
n'avait jamais vu d'armes et là
maintenant ça commence à j'espère que
c'est un
on espère que c'est un cas isolé une
période qui va être réglé parce que
jusqu'à présent la duchère était un
caillou un quartier assez calme on
connaissait pas ce genre de problème
avec des armes du moins cet habitant qui
se plaint de voir l'apparition d'armes
est ce que c'est un phénomène global est
ce que c'est un phénomène uniquement
dans ce quartier on devient davantage
violentes dans les quartiers il y a
davantage d'armes vrai ou faux will vrai
il ya un déni politique là pour le coup
moi ça me rappelle l'épisode
des tchétchènes à dijon où le maire de
dijon devant les vidéos qui montraient
des armes dernière génération exhibé par
les clans locaux disait je n'ai pas vu
d'armes sur les vidéos donc il ya un
déni du politique ça il faut pas le nier
sur le fait que oui il y à des caches
d'armes dans ces quartiers là un arsenal
même récemment à marseille d'ailleurs un
arsenal énorme a été saisi avec des
lances mortier avec des gilets
pare-balles enfin vraiment tout un
arsenal de guerre quasiment donc il faut
pas se voiler la face je crois que là
aussi c'est du devoir de politique
d'arrêter un d'être angélique ou de
croire que ça va s'arranger tout
simplement et le risque évidemment et
tout le monde en est conscient c'est l'
escalade c'est si jamais vous voulez
aller chercher ces armes ou faire comme
l'ont fait ses agents de la bac qui hier
soir confronté les dealers aux points de
deal et bien voilà maintenant les
réponses qu'ils ont c'est à dire des
personnes qui n'hésitent pas à tirer sur
les forces de l'ordre donc le danger il
est réel pour les agents de police il
est réel pour les habitants et la
réponse elle doit être évidemment
exemplaire et elle doit être coordonnée
parce que envoyer le raid un contrecoup
pour finalement de fouiller deux barres
de hlm et repartir les mains vides ça ne
fonctionne pas donc il faut la un plan
peut-être nationale qui doit être
coordonnée par le ministre en
l'occurrence avec la police nationale
avec les unités spéciales pour saisir
ces armes parce que ça devient vraiment
catastrophique et on va voir ce genre de
malheureusement de passes d'armes se
multiplier sur le territoire marseille
bien sûr à les règlements de comptes
entre trafiquants mais maintenant les
forces de l'ordre vont également être
pris pour cible c'est déjà le cas
également sur le terrain mais pas
forcément par des armes et des tirs de
mortiers de feux d'artifice les pompiers
également donc cette violence on l'a
laissé s'installer de peur justement de
l' escalade aujourd'hui l'escaladent
elle est là on tire à balles réelles sur
des policiers en intervention donc il va
falloir
dire et ça le ministre ne peut pas non
plus faire un discours et tout mettre
sur le dos des élus locaux c'est aussi
là au ministère et la police nationale
de prendre les dispositions qui sont
nécessaires et décide de choses dans ce
que vient de me dire alexis poulain le
déni par rapport à tous politiques
concernant cette question des armes et
aussi on laisse peut-être faire la
violence de peur que ça explose vraiment
votre avis en fait tout savoir qu'on a
mis en place une stratégie du
harcèlement c'est tragique du
harcèlement sous-entend qu'on essaye de
d'appréhender et de chimie au maximum du
trafic de stupéfiants voilà donc on est
présent le plus souvent possible on fait
des passages ont interpellé les auteurs
les vendeurs on interpelle les
consommateurs on et verbalisent ambert
mali ce qui tourne avec un escalier tout
l'arsenal juridique aujourd'hui et
administratifs qui est mise en place
donc oui effectivement c'est les
personnes qui sont ces malheureux dire
ça mais omnibulé par l'argent c'est
totalement vie n'a à aucun moment les
règlements de compte c'est pour une
histoire d'ego c'est vraiment des gens
qui n'ont aucun intérêt que l'appât du
gain c'est du nil néo libéralisme
exacerbé en taxi depuis hier en fait on
en passe de personnes qui ne veulent que
gagner d'argent un point de lille à
marseille c'est entre 30 et 80 mille
euros par jour et c'est pas
effectivement 3 mars et c'est pareil
dans toutes les villes de france donc de
chiffre d'affaires donc donc est
aujourd'hui dont copie nous irons les
voir puisqu'il harcèleront plus nous
gênerons le trafic c'est ça le business
il n'y a pas d'autre mot puisse
effectivement cnra mois voire doit être
on va avoir les nerfs exacerbée pascal
falloir rembourser parce que quand on
interpelle effectivement des auteurs
qu'on interpelle du poids du produit
stupéfiant qu'on attrayante de l'argent
et ce alors que les pratiquants de les
rembourser à leur grossiste
effectivement non cumul des dettes donc
à ce moment là effectivement ils sont
sur les dents quand nous venons gêner le
travail où tu paies firme par leur
présence nous interpellons le char
bonheur le dealer le guetteur et et nous
sommes là tous les jours dans une casse
ont effectivement leur économie soit
disant pérenne selon le et
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement qu'ils y
viennent donc c'est pour ça qu'on n'a
pas d'individus qui sont le plus en plus
déterminé parce qu'on gâche le plus en
plus effectivement la perspective d'un
bandage fiducie quel qu'il soit donc oui
effectivement on est en face à des
individus qui monte crescendo parce que
le harcèlement que nous leur mettons en
passer aujourd'hui il veut le plus en
plus important donc malheureusement il
faut absolument trouver des solutions
pour de l'écarter de façon pérenne et
pour pouvoir effectivement au niveau
pénal que c'est une émission appréhender
loin de ces quartiers là le plus
longtemps possible et on va terminer ce
débat avec un message télégramme
spectatrice fabien possible que votre
douce et préfèrent la liberté à la
surveillance systématique du citoyen
s'il n'a pas décidé de truffes et sa
ville de caméras comme le souhaite le
ministre est bien la liberté a toujours
un prix peut-être aussi celui d'un
moindre contrôle de la délinquance nous
dit fais bien justement lexip ou lens
était ce j'essayais de dire tout alors
peut-être une autre approche tout
simplement et il faut parfois peut-être
en payer le prix oui alors évidemment
mais enfin payer le prix si c'est au
prix de vies humaines je crois que c'est
pas c'est pas un bon calcul est donc il
ya un vrai sujet de société sur la
sécurité mais aussi sur le trafic et à
grande échelle s'attaquer au cartel
c'est une coordination internationale
que ce soit interpol et autres et la
vidéoprotection attention c'est un terme
de novlangue la vidéo n'a jamais protégé
en réalité elle permet de surveiller
elle permet peut-être d'identifier des
hauteurs de larcins mais c'est a
posteriori c'est très difficile d'agir
si on voit quelque chose se passait de
toute façon donc ira leurs quelque part
c'est comme si on fait croire aux gens
que la vidéoprotection va les protéger
non elle elle les surveille elle permet
de surveiller de voir qui sont les
auteurs mais encore une fois il faut une
réponse coordonnée il faut des policiers
sur le terrain et il faut s'attaquer au
trafic de grande ampleur au cartel parce
que évidemment quand on est sur un point
de lille c'est le maillon faible c'est
la fin du trafic mais et c'est
extrêmement difficile de démanteler
évidemment ces réseaux de trafic il y en
a eu 1 récemment aux pays bas et les
porcs sont bien entendu des lieux de
passage donc il ya tout un travail de
fond qu'on ne voit pas évidemment
puisque c'est l'intelligence et la
sécurité intérieure qui sont aussi
responsables de cette protection là
parce que le deal peut continuer
longtemps parce que c'est un business
qui rapporte comme vient de le dire
monsieur et ça va continuer parce que il
n'y a pas d'autres débouchés parce qu a
pas de débat non plus sur comment
encadrer aussi si on devait légaliser ou
non certaines drogues comme le cannabis
ou
d'autres drogues moins dure que celle
qui existe ce débat là il a un peu lieu
à l'assemblée nationale mais encore une
fois si vous allez dire c'est un choix
de société c'est un débat politique et
il ya beaucoup de politique dans la
question de sécurité et de liberté et on
peut le comprendre mais je crois que
citoyen comme élus locaux n'ont pas
intérêt à ce que la délinquance se
multiplient et profite du traffic
évidemment merci beaucoup alexis poulin
et d'ici d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage ce soir